None of the tombs were booby traps.
There were false doors to some tombs,
a corridor designed to lead a
potential thief to a dead end.
I'm Anthony Browder,
author of "Nile Valley
Contributions to Civilization"
and director of the ASA
Restoration Project,
currently excavating and
restoring three Kushite tombs.
Today, we're going to be looking
at ancient Egyptian history
in film and determining how real they are.
[Anthony laughs]
The top of a sarcophagus that size
would've weighed more than an automobile.
All of the sarcophagi
that I've seen in Egypt
were made of stone.
If you can imagine trying
to push an automobile
with two hands, it
would've been impossible.
The thieves who broke
into tombs such as these,
there were typically several men,
and they used heavy-duty instruments.
Where's the ushabti?
Oh, well.
There would be jewelry on the mummy,
as we saw in this instance.
You would find that there were little caps
that were put on their fingers.
I'm sorry, Mr. Great.
They reference ushabti.
Ushabti are small figurines
of the departed soul that were supposedly
built to assist the dead in the afterlife.
Ushabtis were never put inside
of the bodies of a mummy.
They were typically buried around them,
outside of the sarcophagus,
and in some instances
there were boxes that contained ushabtis.
The idea of someone
going into a tomb and desecrating a tomb,
as this character does,
is quite troubling.
These are historical
artifacts that are priceless.
There are hundreds of tombs in Egypt
that have been raided, similar to this.
It's been happening
for thousands of years.
I would rate it a 0 for
historical accuracy.
One of the things that I liked
about this particular film,
if you were to walk into
a well-preserved tomb,
the colors would be as
vibrant today as they were
when the tomb was created 3,000 years ago.
One of the most spectacular tombs in Egypt
in the Valley of the Kings
is the tomb of Seti I.
And the colors are so rich, so vibrant,
it looks as if it was
just painted recently.
The images on the wall
of a priest coming before Osiris,
that is an image that comes
from the papyrus of Hunefer.
So this is an accurate depiction
of a 19th-dynasty personality.
It is a depiction that comes
straight from his papyrus,
and so I appreciate the
attention to detail.
These glyphs depicted in this
scene are not accurate glyphs.
The one symbol that is
accurate is the wavy line.
And then that's an easy
glyph to replicate.
It's gibberish, but it looks good.
It helps to sell the movie.
I'm not aware of any of
the ancient Egyptians
using a quartz crystal, if you will,
to illuminate a specific
portion of a temple or a tomb,
but what we do know is that
there were a number of temples
in ancient Egypt which
were oriented to the sun.
For example, at Karnak
Temple, there is an event
that takes place every winter
at the winter solstice:
A beam of sunlight shines down
the eastern part of the temple,
and it would illuminate this
room with a ray of light,
similar to what you see here in the film.
I would give it a 10 for production value.
The set designer gets a lot of credit
for doing their research.
What you saw in this battle scene
were what I consider to be
fairly accurate representations
of the chariots, of the
armor, and the weapons
that were used by the ancient
Egyptians and their enemies.
There was a chariot
buried in King Tut's tomb.
And King Tut lived about
100 years before Ramses,
who we see in this particular scene.
There are many texts in Egypt
that describe battles such as this.
The most famous archers
in the Egyptian army
were the Nubians. They were considered
the best archers in the Nile valley.
Typically one would find
on the outer pylon of temples
images of the king in a
chariot going into battle
to defend Egypt against
the enemies of Egypt.
This was, I guess, royal propaganda,
to show that the king was
the protector of the land.
Ridley Scott directed
this particular film.
He gives great attention to detail.
I give him a 10 on this depiction.
Ardeth: Thebes, home of Imhotep.
Pharaoh's high priest, keeper of the dead.
Well, actually, Imhotep
was a third-dynasty priest
to the King Djoser in Saqqara,
which is in northern Egypt.
Imhotep was the historical
personality who was responsible
for creating the step pyramid of Saqqara.
Imhotep is also considered
to be the world's first multigenius.
He was a physician, deified by the Greeks.
He also was an architect and an engineer.
Ardeth: Birthplace of
Ankhesenamun, pharaoh's mistress.
The reference to Ankhesenamun
as the mistress of Seti I
is an extreme case of someone
taking liberty with the truth.
Ankhesenamun was actually
the wife of King Tut,
who was a 18th-dynasty personality,
and Seti I was a 19th-dynasty personality.
So these two historical figures,
and they are real historical figures,
but they lived about a
century apart from each other.
So I have no knowledge of Seti I
having a mistress by the
name of Ankhesenamun.
He is depicted in this film
as having murdered the king.
There is no historical evidence
of Imhotep murdering the king.
The representation of
Imhotep and the other priests
as being clean-shaven was accurate.
Typically, every priest
in Egypt was clean-shaven.
It was an act of cleanliness,
and it was an act of respect
for the positions that they
held within each temple.
Ardeth: Ankhesenamun's soul had been sent
to the dark underworld,
her vital organs removed
and placed in five sacred canopic jars.
They made reference to,
"her organs were placed
in five canopic jars."
Well, anyone who knows anything
about ancient Egyptian history knows
that there are only four canopic jars,
the stomach, the lungs, and
some of the other organs.
The removal of the organs
was to keep the body clean.
Ardeth: The worst of all ancient curses,
one so horrible had never
before been bestowed.
The reference to Imhotep's
tongue being cut out,
to my knowledge, that was not done.
Ardeth: Imhotep's priests were condemned
to be mummified alive.
I'm not aware of any person
being mummified alive.
Mummification was a very time-consuming
and expensive process,
so there's no reason
why a person in the past
would've been buried alive.
And the process of
mummification in ancient Egypt
typically took place over
the course of 70 days.
The idea of booby traps
in ancient Egyptian tombs
is something that comes
from the imagination
of film writers. None of
the tombs were booby traps.
There were false doors to some tombs,
a corridor designed to lead a
potential thief to a dead end.
There were false corridors,
and there were shafts
to prevent thieves from coming in
to access the treasure
that was buried in a tomb,
but there were no booby
traps that I'm aware of.
I would give it a minus 1.
It is wholly historically inaccurate.
As they're moving this very heavy statue,
they're asking the woman to pour grease
underneath the statue.
No one knows what methods
they actually used
to move these heavy objects,
and people take liberties
at guessing how it was done.
Now, there is a famous image in Egypt
where men are moving a statue
and you see a person
standing on top of the statue
and pouring a liquid
in front of the statue,
implying that this liquid is being used
to ease the movement of
this statue across the sand.
We don't stop a moving
block for an old woman!
Mercy, Prince Moses!
Come here.
Not for myself, Lord Prince, for a slave.
It's an issue that's been
debated for centuries,
but there is no evidence whatsoever
of slaves having built the pyramids.
First and foremost, there
are 118 pyramids in Egypt.
And more specifically when
people speak of pyramids,
they're thinking of the
three great pyramids of Giza,
the pyramids of Khufu,
Khafre, and Menkaure.
Those pyramids were all built
during the fourth dynasty,
which is around 2400 BC.
That's at least 1,200 years before
the story of Moses took place.
In recent years, Egyptian
archeologists have actually
found the tombs of the
builders of the pyramids
adjacent to the Giza Plateau.
That honor would not have
been given to a slave.
We know that it was built
by master craftsmen,
master masons, master engineers.
Would you bury the old woman
alive in a tomb of rock?
And there's also one other misnomer
that I think is important to talk about.
The pyramids were not used as tombs.
Pyramids were built over tombs.
I would rate the depiction of the movement
of a large box of stone as accurate.
The idea of someone putting
grease underneath a block
to help ease this
movement across the sand,
that's not accurate at all.
This story depicts the
battle between Horus and Set,
and it is the second part of the story
of the founding of Egypt.
This is a story that is
over 6,000 years old.
In this particular instance,
the animal depiction
of Set is not a jackal,
it's an unidentified animal.
A jackal was associated with Anubis,
who was the guardian of the dead.
He was the person who led
the souls into the afterlife.
The depiction of Horus as a falcon
had to do with the symbolism
associated with the falcon.
A falcon has keen eyesight.
Doing Egypt a favor.
You're not fit to be king.
[laughs]
No, there were not British
white guys in Egypt.
When this picture came out,
there was a great deal of controversy,
because there's been a
great deal of contention
over the last 100 years or so
as to the race of the Egyptians.
And a lot of it unfortunately
has to do with racism,
because many of the early
founders of Egyptology
happened to be white men who
believed that Black people
were inherently inferior to white.
The original name for Egypt was Kemet.
Kemet is a word which means
the land of the Blacks.
History has been used as
a tool to subjugate people
and to create false notions
of superiority and inferiority.
Thoth, I only need --
The answer to the riddle of the sphinx.
A child could deduce why you're here.
Thoth, the god of wisdom, science,
astronomy, and knowledge,
who was known in the
original language as Djehuty.
In this particular instance,
Chad Boseman was quite aware
of ancient Egyptian history,
and he chose to play this role
so that the position of Thoth
could be accurately depicted
by a person of African ancestry.
I appreciate the fact
that Chad wanted to add
a sense of historical accuracy
to this particular character.
If I was to rate this
film, the "Gods of Egypt,"
I would give it a 0.
If I were to rate the scenes
with Chadwick Boseman,
I would say give it a 5.
It contains truth, but it is not true.
I will see to that.
The kohl, the dark lining around the eyes,
women wore it and men wore it.
That was used primarily as protection
from the intense sunlight.
It's the same thing that you see
on a football field or a baseball field
where the athlete would put
black underneath their eye
to absorb the intense rays of sunlight
so that they could see clearly.
In the name of the senate,
and the people of Rome, and by their will.
Their representations of the clothing,
the headdresses, is pretty accurate
based on the physical
evidence that was left.
The two staffs that we
see Cleopatra holding
are the crook and the flail.
The crook is the shepherd's crook,
and it indicates that the king, the ruler,
is a shepherd to the
people of their country.
The flail is an instrument that
is similar to a fly swatter,
and it's used to swat away
distractions, enemies of Egypt.
If you combine these two instruments,
then what they represent is
the king or queen's ability
to protect the people of the land
and to do away with
the enemies of the land
who would bring danger and
threats to the territory.
There cannot be enough hours
in the days of a queen.
Again, the use of white
actresses to depict Cleopatra
is taking liberties with historical truths
based on the archeological
evidence that has been found
of Cleopatra's sisters
and other family members.
She was probably closer to Halle Berry
than Elizabeth Taylor.
Now, there's also very little evidence
to indicate how Cleopatra died.
So the idea of her holding
an asp to her breast
and it biting her, it's fiction.
There is no evidence to validate
that is how Cleopatra died.
I give it a 7.
My favorite of the clips that we've seen
is "Raiders of the Lost Ark."
The narrative was fictional,
but the presentation of the artifacts
was as real as can be.
If you enjoyed this video,
click the link for more
exciting information.